29 hours a barricade comes to a peaceful
end in the south valley but the facts
surrounding it are really wild thanks
for joining us at five i'm bryan loftis
and i'm denise valdez hostages were
involved in all of this including a
young boy
it happened at a motel near blue diamond
in dean martin that's where we find
oracle manna now live with the details
[Music]
denise and brian metro police say the
suspect took a four-year-old boy and his
babysitter hostage when he barricaded
himself
inside this motel here behind me we're
getting a closer look at this scene and
there's still a heavy police presence
out here
this was an extremely dynamic situation
that ended peacefully with no injuries
and those hostages are safe now this all
started yesterday morning around 10
30 when an officer saw the suspect
described it's a hispanic man
trying to get away with the stolen
vehicle they got into a fight
and then the man went to pull out a gun
from his vest the officer stepped back
due to safety and then the suspect ran
inside the motel we're told he fired his
gun toward officers while inside
he then used a hammer and a saw to cut a
hole in the wall so he could get into
another room
that's when he took the four-year-old
boy and his female babysitter
hostage crisis negotiators talked with
the suspect for hours
and he eventually let the boy go and
then after negotiating overnight
and into this afternoon the suspect let
the babysitter go
police were then able to convince the
suspect to surrender
metro saying officers took all the right
steps
there is a time where they need to use
force and move quickly
but they also recognize that this was
one of those times that time
we could slow down communicate the
subject was willing to communicate with
us
and we use all of the negotiation
tactics available to us
to bring this to a peaceful resolution
the suspect faces several charges
including assault with the deadly weapon
kidnapping and attempted murder on a
police officer
again back out here live metro police
still on scene conducting their
investigation
after this 29 hour hostage barricade
situation so again
a very dynamic situation here but again
the suspect was taken into custody
and the hostages are safe reporting live
tonight orca mana 8 news now